it really makes a difference what we say
I learnt this from a woman who survived
out this he went to Auschwitz when she
was fifteen years old and her brother
was eight and the parents were lost and
she told me this we were in the train
going to Auschwitz and I looked down I
saw my brother's shoes were missing and
I said you stupid you keep your
things together for goodness sake the
way an elder sister might speak to a
younger brother unfortunately it was the
last thing she ever said to him because
she never saw him again
he did not survive and so when she came
out about to it she made a vow she said
I walked out of Auschwitz into life and
the vow was I will never say anything
that couldn't stand as the last thing I
ever say now can we do that no but it is
a possibility to live into thank you
Oh